it's the fighter and the kid had to run
it back cause we back at it again yeah
we gon keep it moving like it's never
gonna end when it was brendan when it
was brian when he was just talking to
friends we got the kid calling on the
left with the fighter on the right had
to do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this is really the fighter in the kit
we're out come on baby yeah yeah
yeah that's a lot of fire power 500 mil
back in the day back in those days it's
like yeah everybody right now
so i figured that was a little bit of a
problem
so so when when uh
ronald reagan declared war on organized
crime and giuliani said the same thing
he basically said if you're a member of
an organized crime family i'm i'm
declaring war on you
what'd you guys think about that because
you guys i remember when the fulton fish
market caught fire mysteriously
well i mean it was a problem you know
when you have multiple agencies like
that you're [ __ ] with the government
you've got state organized crime the
federal law guys crime bureaus different
uh states
putting their
you know
people prosecutors together it's a war
and it's hard to fight them they make
the laws
so
you're fighting people that uh
that don't lose that don't lose they
don't lose the government no no the fbi
doesn't just beat them right
well they haven't
they have a 98 conviction rate yeah why
do you think that is
they have the best lawyers correct
they have the best investigators
you know i did time i did 22 years in
prisons i was with so many guys
especially black guys
turned around and said sam what do you
think on this case i think you're dead
why because you got some broken down
[ __ ] lawyer yeah
and uh your prosecutor is an ex-cop an
ex-drunk
and uh they have a team of magnificent
lawyers
they have the fbi as their investigators
and they have a 98
conviction rate because they make the
laws yeah
most people think they're smarter than
that most people would say most people
think they're smarter than the fbi but
the fbi's got some smart plus you
organized crime yeah right they got well
and
the laws i mean they have bugs yeah
they're people confidential informants
they got everything going for for them
so you're going into a fight
you know i'm looking at these guys in
this room over here all these big
[ __ ] that i mean i'm going to
fight them the both of them
i i've got to be on my mind if i think
i'm going to win i'm going to fight but
finally
i got i got to just i got to give you an
intro for people who don't know because
for me people don't understand my
generation
sammy the bull gravano
the man sitting here was the underboss
that means he was the number two guy in
the most powerful organized crime family
in the united states and that was not a
that was not a matter of dispute the
boss of all bosses was
castellano who sat at the head of the
commission and all the other crime
families from all over the country would
sit under him and take orders from him
and sammy
was the underboss of the gambino crime
family and the guy who really who
started to become the guy who called all
the shots
because you were the guy that's that
ultimately
everybody seemed to be respecting wanted
to be around and it became evident to
john gotti that you were probably going
to take over in one way or another right
yeah he he became uh very illyrio is
john gotti was a complicated guy because
he's an egomaniac he's a narcissist
and uh
so everything meant something to him
uh
he was concerned with a lot of things
with me after we took over frankie chico
was the main player got blown up four
months after the castellano hit but
after a while
i'm going to give you a quick story that
a captain in the genovese family came to
john in the club
and i know it because guys were around
and they says
john you know how to pick them
meaning that
i'm the underboss
he said uh why
they said sammy says you can't do a job
in the city no more unless you get a
[ __ ] wink and a nod from him
became a super powerhouse yeah now
me if somebody told me about one of my
people i would say that's great you need
something done i'll talk to him i'll get
it done for you good ass
tremendous asset
but he looked at it in as a narcissist
would
jealous he don't want somebody to be his
equal that's his ego right and i i you
know i i'm
i would say if if you go back and look
over like all the history all that stuff
a lot of the
kind of the downfall of the the entire
organized crime a lot of it was due to
gotti's ego when you think about the
moves he made as far as getting to the
drug business it's like
you know listen luciano even said like
we don't want to get involved with drugs
because that's that's what attracts the
attracts the fed yeah like the drug was
we don't need to do it you guys are
doing all this stuff you want to get
involved with the drugs and then also
you know you guys want to fly under the
radar he has two thousand dollar suits
on he's doing the interviews he's on the
cover of time you know it's like this
you want to be this celebrity so you're
getting all this attention so to me i
know people want to they i think the
easy out in the way the media portrayed
it is oh sammy is the reason they fell
like man i would argue was gotti i think
he was too wild and his narcissists and
egos
after i left
i was with the government for quite a
while i was living in quantico it's a
military base that they had me put there
and
they told me john was a blessing
oh yeah i said what do you mean
he gave us the entire mafia all five
families the whole thing the whole
on a silver platter
because the recordings of the the
court's recordings because of the way he
dressed yeah the news media but also he
had everybody come kiss his ring
like every every once a week they'd have
to come to the rape nightclub the whole
the entire every everybody who was made
and come and say hi on the street but
that's the other thing yeah the fbi is
like yeah but that but they're not going
to bust them off that but the raven i
know who he is no
he didn't care about that b the raven
nightclub was bugged and they knew it
but he would still go upstairs and talk
about it
yeah that's a huge issue yes i'm saying
that so many of these guys the fbi
correct me if i'm wrong sammy didn't
they didn't they didn't even know who
they were but until they had they came
out and now you're kissing john they
were like well that guy's a that guy and
that guy and they just wasn't an
important guy we know he was there but
if he wasn't important enough that he
was just doing his thing he's under a
captain
you're never going to see that guy he's
not a well-known guy he's not going to
go sitting with the boss
what this did was take those guys who
were never even really known we knew who
they were but not the government now
they're going there and reporting like
he's saying kiss the ring not actually
kissing the ring but they're coming in
now they're grabbing me
and they're telling me sammy
bro i i
they don't this is and they never had a
picture of me now i'm walking in i see
guys with cameras the news is here the
government is here what are we what is
he doing yeah talk to him please
i said i did i did he's the boss
whatever he wants i i did talk to him i
grabbed his brother jeannie gene gotti
and i said to genie i said gene
go over his house at night you're his
brother you're a friend of ours he was
actually a cap
so i says tell them that all the old
times everybody's complaining this this
is insane what we're doing
he says sammy i did that
and what did he tell you
he said when you want to talk to me
about mommy or the kids or people you're
my brother come and talk to me you want
to talk about girls in austria go
through sammy oh wow
i said he told you that it's amigo yeah
so so listen to the story listen to how
machiavellian gotti was guys it's crazy
but i'm going to talk to
i was telling him a story i'll tell you
the story that
when the guy from the genovese people
said about the
you you can't do a job unless you get a
wink of a nod from sammy another guy
came in the captain from the columbo
family
and said
john
i was at tally's last week on tuesday
sammy does his books and meets his guys
and other people and i went there with
60 [ __ ] guys there
made guys captains under bosses union
bosses
this guy is a [ __ ] powerhouse he's
become
now that struck john in a way
hmm
i was doing a lot of work
i'm sending him on missions
he wants to take me out he could take
over tomorrow
with the power that he has now
so he's trying to undermine me that's
the tapes he got caught on
and he's telling frankie lucasio to go
out basically and tell the captains
sammy lost his mind bro he's killing
[ __ ] people taking over their
businesses is killing people taking over
the unions
both of them not true
and i'll tell you the reason why because
you can't just kill your underboss
if he's liked if he's loved he's
bringing in money to the family he's
doing work now what makes it even
stronger is that he's sending me on hits
to get things done as the underboss
you stop that at the captain level yeah
ozzy on the bus i'm going on the street
so you guys have to hit
he tells me sammy go with that make sure
it gets done
john i'm the underboss bro i did that
you know i'm up on a whole nother level
now god take you got you got to go there
get this done
okay
so i go
now you two guys when i'm not around you
talking and some guys got caught on tape
oh my god this [ __ ] sandman just
sitting on his [ __ ] ass giving orders
he's on the street with a gun with us
these don't work they love you for that
yeah and he see john forced that
situation
so when i come into the club you guys
are sitting there you jump up you see
hey see me you love me for what i'm
doing yeah i'm not just sitting i'm i'm
one of you yeah they respected it i'm
getting the respect so that's where this
all created he created it basically
himself
and then
all my ways i guess and so now he's
starting to spread rumors that i'm doing
this thing because he has a plan to take
me up
but it's so silly because you're such a
big earner right right because if you're
making so much money you know and
obviously that's where his ego
narcissism comes in because making him
so much money but two million it doesn't
matter because he's making millions and
millions of millions so what's when
you're making five or ten million a year
what's the difference one minute yeah
less
but uh the important part is
now he's starting to worry that i could
kill him and take over
now were you thinking about that be
honest oh no absolutely no i wasn't in
your head never never
never
why
why because i why would i do that yeah
we took over the family together me and
him it's us against the world frankie
the chico died i didn't want him as the
boss originally but that's a whole
nother story yeah let's do one at a time
yeah yeah so let's stay with where we're
at right now yeah he wants to do it so
what's his plan and i got to give him
this it was ingenious as a mobster it's
machiavelli to the t
he turns around and he wants to get rid
of me but he can't because everybody
would just say if he could kill him then
we're all nothing yeah
so what is these they're doing this and
putting these phony stories out
then he says sammy
frankie the chico who i love was killed
and you always thought it was chin
was behind it
vinnie the chen
vinnie the chin he was the boss of the
genovese family
um
i think you're right i got a little
information
take them out
music to my ear
music to my ear because i loved frankie
the chico you're close with them yeah
very super close
so tell them how you're setting it up
tell me how you're going to do it
i'm not going to go through the whole
story
yeah but i'm going to say that i was
setting it up ready to go
and uh what's his plan it took a long
time to come out
tapes this that people who cooperated
before i know it like to this point
so i go kill chin
i kill chen i come back
the next day
how'd you make out he's gone
i got
good he immediately kills me
chin hated him
he gets rid of chin
he gets rid of his problem with me
two problems he goes to the genovese
people
sammy i love the guy bro he lost his
mind you could ask anybody who was
killing people taking over unions taking
over this then he came to me that he
killed chin
as much as i loved him i had to kill him
i killed him about that
savage savage it's savage but it's
ingenious it is he gets rid of both of
us
well it was part of his downfall because
he couldn't never keep his [ __ ] mouth
shut or his ego and then also you know
he was
ratting on tapes about you even before
you were and then also you know you guys
have a code where you don't kill people
outside the business and then you know
tragically his son gets ran over by that
neighbor and even if you do an accident
yeah the neighbors the kid is on a bike
shoots in the middle of the road the
neighbor runs over the kid kills the kid
yeah you know what happened that guy he
disappeared yeah he killed him he
tortured him tortured him yeah killed
him well he didn't you know he didn't do
it he gave it to his wife because he
went to florida with his wife that's
right and they called and said i'm in
florida that was his alibi yeah that's
what he did and his crew whoever did it
but still you know but still his orders
to kill this dude who made a mistake but
he's not he's not in your business so
that's already he's breaking the rules
so the media wants to pretend john gotti
always lived by the code but he was
breaking away before it yeah yeah many
of times that's right oh yeah but but i
mean it's
forget codes and everything it's an
accident
yeah it's a [ __ ] accident you can't
kill somebody for an accident imagine i
get up you step on i step on your toe
and you beat me after that i'm still
alive but i don't want those problems
but yeah yeah
yeah
i don't want those don't need that i'm
not going to step back
i don't want any problems
i don't even know maybe you want to
shoot this thing with me all of a sudden
you take me
off and i [ __ ] disappear i don't know
how do i know this isn't the head you
set me up with everything
the camera crew everything in space do
you still ever worry about that sammy no
no right but i i i was
telling
the girl that peyton that it how it
comes back to me it stuck in my brain
all the time i said
we got out we of them playing we got in
a truck there was cameras there was
directors
lighting guys
sound guys
the whole nine yards taking pictures
everything is beautiful and we get in
the car
and we go to manhattan beach and we're
gonna go to the beach and this and that
they get my girl
and they take her in one direction
and they're taking me in another
direction
suspect no it's just but here's here's
the thing i think is immediately the
perfect hit
yeah they took her they'll put her over
there
i go to a meeting bye bye you never see
me i'm thinking the same thing here yeah
yeah god it worked out man yeah but i'm
saying it's a perfect plan because
here's what he does
he's got witnesses
he's got huh as his witness no yeah they
had cameras it was a whole question
his witnesses never know now
he goes to the hotel
and he gets three witnesses
where he dropped me off at the hotel he
left in the car the people say and said
he went up to his room now sometimes you
wish you he perfect that time you
perfect sometimes you wish you put a
bullet in the back your head because the
d4 should play volleyball no no we
didn't do any
volleyball we didn't know volleyball i
didn't let him sit behind me in the car
though i don't know
it's so i asked him i go i we were
talking about like i want to know
because you were in the hole solitary
confinement for six years six and a half
years think about it they put them in
the like you're alone bro and then in
the winter time you get one hour a week
to go out in the yard i'm sure the
food's great yeah you're so alone he was
so desperate he grabbed this nurse's
finger just to talk to him for a second
my question is
how did you speak to yourself how do you
[ __ ] stay safe toughness yeah get
through that how did you not go crazy
yourself in three minutes yeah i was
asked this question a lot of times but
i'm gonna answer it maybe let's take a
little break from chatting with sammy
the legend let's take a look
it's the bull we got the bullet house
i'll tell you why i'm grabbing the bull
by the horns in fort wayne indiana dude
are you july 14th are you grabbing the
[ __ ]
indiana
you're doing a little uh yeah you're
doing a little standing forward wise
guys come on out july fort wayne indiana
july 14th through the 16th and then san
diego lap factory downtown san diego
july 21st through the 23rd bull's out
there too good there's bulls in san
diego dude and i'm also grabbing the
bulls by the horn in baltimore really
yeah same with the bull all right by the
horns all right august 4th through the
6th baltimore appleton houston boston's
all on there thickboy.com get you some
tickets cause i'll tell you what now if
you like watching my little tv show
called uh uh um got it
wow messed up all best up you go watch
that on youtube but forget all that
that's a lot of fun we got some fun
stuff coming up we got brookfield
wisconsin you want if you're in
milwaukee or anywhere around there
i'm grabbing the bull by the horns out
there i'm going july 21 22 23 i'll be at
the milwaukee improv now there's
actually going to be bulls in austin
there are definitely bulls in austin
texas
ladies at your show
yeah
uh
cass city's july 28th 29th 30th they
opened up i'm excited
nashville yeah the fun ones dude zany's
august 26 27 it says 25 there but it's
actually 26 27. then i got spokane
washington spokane comedy club september
22 24.
i want to talk about ufc is there a way
to bet on the ufc dude there's
definitely a way to bet on the ufc you
can watch the fight companion this
saturday live on think boy youtube we
got a monster lineup come for you guys
got trevor wallace the youtube sensation
the beast comic we got josh thompson we
got luke rockhold we'll all be there
live for ufc 276. you can watch that on
takeaway at 7 p.m uh pacific live on
think boy youtube and you watch and make
money with draftking sportsbook the
official sports betting partner of the
ufc and they have a heavyweight offer
this weekend's fight with a special
parlay for all the listeners and viewers
of firing the kid for the fires this
week my picks are izzy suga and
barbarina he's fighting robbie
lawler he's the only slight dog there i
think he's a minus 105. it's a great
freaking uh pick but all three have to
win and then all you gotta do just head
to the app right now under the ufc page
check out my picks bet on it and ride
along with your thick friend here right
now all customers can place the same
game parlay for saturday's fight if it
hits you double your winnings download
the draftking sportsbook app now use
promo code fighter new customers can bet
five dollars on any ufc 276 fighter to
win and get 100 in free bets no matter
what that's code fighter this saturday
at draftkings sportsbook the official
sports brand partner the ufc minimum age
and eligibility restrictions supply
seashell notes for details
my question is
how did you speak to yourself how do you
[ __ ] stay safe toughness yeah through
that how did you not go crazy off
yourself in three minutes yeah i was
asked this question a lot of times but
i'm gonna answer it
that
we all
have no idea
how much we have in us
if something that we can't control like
a plane crashes and we're stuck on a
[ __ ] island yeah we have you have no
idea how much you could withdraw from
your body to survive and to do certain
things and you know but being in the
hole like that
i mean it was the worst time of my life
six and a half years i just it was
incredible but i did i knew they wanted
to break me yeah and that was my mental
frame so i did sit-ups i did push-ups i
did crunches i talked to myself and i
called it the adx strut would walk
around the cell talking to myself
answering myself
and
trying anything i had one visit while i
was in the adx my wife came down she's
my ex-wife now
and she came on a visit
and i went there
and uh
it's a booth i go into a booth
she's on the other side in a booth my
side faces the president side faces
those machines and stuff and
they came with lunch
they opened the slot pushed the tray in
i got it and it says hey there's no
utensils
they close the slot eat with your hands
all right
i said deb go in the machines and get
what you want
you have to talk on a phone the glass is
so thick you can't hear it over my head
there's a camera looking at her over her
head there's a camera looking at me
so i'm sitting there and i'm eating
a phone
on my cheek talking on and eating with
my hands
and she's talking that her voice blurred
away from me not that it was i couldn't
hear that mentally i said
look what i'm becoming a total [ __ ]
animal
she's sitting there
i'm in the cage she's in a cage and i'm
eating [ __ ] food with my hands and i
don't even have nothing to wipe it on
i says
what a mistake this [ __ ] visit is
i hit the buzzer a little bit
the female guard came up what is it
i got to go to the bathroom
all right
put your hands through the
the slot i put my hands through she
cuffed my hands
i come out
she takes me in the hole i walk down the
hall at the end of the hole there's this
chicken wire like you know regular yeah
around this
area and a bowl against the wall that's
it
no barriers no nothing
so i went in there i uncuffed
shawn cuffed me to a slot and i went in
and i says uh
could you go down the hall a little bit
she said i have to stand here and watch
i said i don't have to take a piss i
have to take a [ __ ]
please
could you go down the hall
i have to stand here this camera's there
i can't walk away
it's the first time in my life
i [ __ ] in front of a woman
it was so [ __ ]
i was demoralized yeah they'll do it
yeah i mean i never felt like that i was
so humiliated i was
i was literally sick to my stomach and i
i never did that in my life
i didn't feel between eating with my
hands and now this i didn't feel like a
human being anymore
i felt like a total [ __ ] animal and
did you have regrets of the lifestyle at
that point well when i left and i got
back in
i got in there i got the phone i told my
wife i said listen babe
you spent about two thousand with
airfare hotel you're gonna be here too
that don't let anybody come here and
don't come back
i don't ever want another visit here
again
don't come back
it's just saying you get one call a
month
one [ __ ] call a month and they're on
the phone they're listening they can
shut you down
you
you got to have a call you got to be
human you have kids at this point too oh
i got kids yeah yeah they always had
kids so
that was it i never got another visit i
told her please just don't i didn't
explain to her
what
just took
happened when i went to the bathroom
and uh i'm married
i had girlfriend i never went to the
bedroom like that no in my life
i would ask for a mail girl hey can we
get the mail guard yeah right
now
you're not going to give us all this
just like i told her i didn't you know
what that you
i don't think she's happy about it i
didn't know she don't want to let you
take a [ __ ]
sucks too yeah yeah both
it was
i became so
hungry for conversation
that a female nurse came she i i liked
her she was friendly she was a nice
woman seemed like a nice person
she was talking about a letter that my
daughter had sent and she was had the
letter in the hand she was
your daughter's a good writer and she
was talking about this that and the
other thing and uh
she handed it to me through the buzz and
i and i got it and i was reading it a
little bit and she was talking to me
about it
and uh she says all right i'm gonna go
and i have to give it a letter back when
i gave her the letter back she took her
with one hand
and
she said i'm gonna go
i don't even know what made me do it i
swear to god i'm trying to think what
made me do i had no idea but i grabbed
her finger i went to grab my hand but i
grabbed the finger
and i said i begged her not to leave to
talk to me
and she said sammy this camera's all
over
and know what you're going through
if they see you hanging onto my hand
should you try to pull and fight
because they would have saw that yeah
she said they'll come and
beat your [ __ ] brains in
i know what you're going through they're
overdoing it with you
please let go my finger
and i let go
i said i wasn't trying to hurt you
she said i know
do push-ups
do
ups meditate
[ __ ] them
that's how good of a person he says yeah
stay strong i will come back and forth
and talk to you
make it
don't let them break you jesus can
there's no there was no way your lawyers
could say this guy's in i mean he's in
the hole for six [ __ ] years
the government doesn't care
no listen cha cha bones in there already
now he got bigger
he's going crazy who is chocolate el
chapo they give him i don't think he
gets an hour outside he is no they'll
give him an hour he's going crazy his
wife uh who's in prison now too but she
submit thing to the prison like he's
legit going insane of course and they go
yeah how do you think this works well
you can run a drug cartel and kill
thousands of people and yeah what do you
think it was
that would be cruel and unusual
punishment though we do have laws
against that right isn't i mean if you
do the [ __ ] should we do give him a a
double
no no but i mean i think that no kill
him there's that's what i say if that's
how you feel kill him in other words you
can't say uh uh [ __ ] him he's a criminal
and and and and
in other words we have no values no
morals you you can't call him a criminal
when you're going to do that to him well
you're just not much more criminal as he
is but that's the argument i'm not
saying you i'm talking about system yeah
that's the argument against torture the
argument against torture was made
specifically for that reason so we're
just like them
it's it's also it's also but it also
corrupts the society it's very very
difficult it's why it's why like we all
would like to torture some people right
if you left it up to well but the idea
of retribution
is is a very different thing than the
idea of taking somebody who's a danger
to society and putting them away and the
idea against cruel and unusual
punishment back in the day they would
torture you they'd do terrible things
but the argument becomes isolation for a
human being over that long a period
where you actually lose your mind is
torture let me let me bring one up
because hey this came up too yeah
uh uh
guantanamo bay i think it is it's on
cuba yeah we got terrorists
who are blowing us up killing us the
most horrendous way
we catch them we put them there for
years
they military food which is pretty damn
good
they have military doctors which is
pretty damn good compared to prison
they gave them a soccer field
yeah they go out every day
these were americans yeah i don't give a
[ __ ] what they did
you're going to treat them because it's
compassionate and it looks good for the
rest of the world correct but you're
going to get our people
and do horrendous things now uh uh
serial killers or somebody who does
really weird [ __ ] yeah and i'm going for
it pedophiles yeah kill them but you
can't
you can't torture people
and then you're feeling sorry for them
so the world don't think you're a maniac
but you're doing it to your own people
yeah
that's like
russia has got some real tough [ __ ]
prisons oh yeah they're not gonna show
you what they're doing to those people
no because they don't want to look like
animals yeah but they should look like
animals to their own people that's the
point you can't become them
you can't not i hate a pedophile
but i'm going to become a pedophiler
yeah right just to punish him i'm going
to become him so what would you do
kill him just take him out take them
save a lot of tax dollars tax dollars a
whole bunch of things and it'll be a
more of a deterrent not that you're
going to baby somebody for 20 [ __ ]
years and and we're going to pay them a
fortune just to feed them and keep them
healthy and do all these [ __ ] things
if he was that bad off and all these
things take him out take him the [ __ ]
out some people don't belong breathing
anymore now and i agree with this yeah i
don't care if it was me and if you
thought i i shouldn't be breathing take
me the [ __ ] out i would rather you take
me out than do [ __ ] 30 years or six
and a half years seven years old give me
the firing squad right
in front of a female how long do you
think they'll keep el chapo in solitary
like that for whatever whatever oh the
answer's forever sir the answer is he's
escaped three prisons we can't that's uh
he's got rabbit on his in other words
he's escaped three prizes you ain't
getting out of this place no but but
it's underground those are mexican
things yeah and everybody's in on it so
but when you got rabbit on on you on
your jacket rabbit means you're gonna
run did you guys ever deal did you guys
when you were running the gambino crime
family did you guys deal with other the
families from other countries
yes
you did yes the irish right in philly
you dealt with them a lot no they were
they just did we we dealt with a lot of
people i don't i i was locked up with a
guy named
doggety
he was a uh uh an ira member
and i did time with him he's a good guy
um
he was in an english prison
and he broke out
on the way out of prison they killed a
god
one of the they think they killed two
guards one of the gods was margaret
thatcher's nephew
jeez
so you killed the president's nephew
whoa you're going away and he got away
he came into the united states and the
mafia hooked him up down in manhattan in
the bar irish neighborhood
and
got him a job
but that uh
they found him
and they arrested him in the united
states
and he fought extradition and because
they would have tortured the [ __ ] out of
him so he fought extradition for years i
was with him he was even writing
articles for a newspaper for a while
below mcc they have doggety square they
named the square after him
he was doing a lot of time there i think
it was
president bush the the father the first
one
who
even though he won all his decisions
shipped his ass back at night
to england
and they you know he's probably better
off there's room in in
a
prison over there yeah there's certain
prisons that they have there
that
the inmates run the thing the ira there
were so many of them i don't know now
this was more years ago they had that
they had it locked down because they
used to say if you were irish and you
were if you were irish in those jails
the british were going to mess you up so
what they would do is if you were an ira
guy they'd go to the head guy the
british the guy the english guy who ran
the prison shot caller and and they'd go
that's your address right is that your
address that's the home of your guys
living yeah yeah good
you you [ __ ] with us we'll blow it to
smithereens
one better here's what they did too they
wouldn't take orders
from the english
gods
in other words they only had in other
words the god had to go he's the boss
the head-eye all right guy they will go
to him this is what we need done okay he
gets his people the irish guys to get
those things done that's power they
won't take orders from them
so they would compromise with the boss
and he had a little bit of power to get
better better food better medical
attention but he they had to go to him
you couldn't go to me as his underling
and tell me to do it i would tell you
hey
yeah he's i'll listen to him i ain't
listening to you sammy were you ever
worried in prison they were going to try
and get in there even not even
uh mafia business but just in general
i got along in prison so [ __ ] good it
was amazing i get along with people yeah
i was
i have odin on my arm
the abs allowed me to put that the aryan
brotherhood
because
i became very friendly with them
a lot of times they would ask me for
structure how did you structure the
mafia what's the structure
i would tell them what do you want to
know for your abs
wait a minute for you what's the
difference well you lasted hundreds if
not thousands of years so your structure
isn't
nobody ever had a structure like you
people
so i talked with them
i used to play
chess
through walls uh
uh with this guy
uh schneider paul schneider
they used to call him corn fed real well
big muscular guy not what weights or
anything just natural like a [ __ ]
farmer real muscular but all natural no
working out no nothing he's just a beast
and i got friendly with him he had four
life bits he was nobody went in the yard
with him nobody would go in the yard
with him so he couldn't get in the yard
because he was just killed his or what
well he
fought he went in with a sentence three
other life sentences were killing people
within the
to prisons yeah so he's got nothing to
lose he just got another one he don't
care so nobody would go in in the yard
with him and he was so [ __ ] big this
guy was you know so anyway he's telling
me about it we're playing
because i had asked him why don't you go
in the [ __ ] yard bro he said
somebody's got to sign me and i can't
get in
so nobody was willing to sign uh okay
jesus
and that's all it's got to be yeah
i said all right i called the lieutenant
and i said listen we're gonna go out
tomorrow yeah uh put me in the yard with
him
confront
are you sure sammy he knows of history i
know he's got four lives i know all
about him
i know about it it's cool he's my friend
i think
my friend i think well i know i don't
know for sure you go out there's doing
cartwheels no when they take me out the
next day he got out first he's in the
back of the yard he's got his shirt off
the sun is beating on him oh my god he
looked like a [ __ ] goddess i tell you
the truth i mean
i said
you know i'm i'm putting i got my hands
through the thing they're uncovering me
i'm saying i wonder if this was a
mistake yeah okay so i said but [ __ ] it
i mean it's done now so take the cuff
off because
in there they tell you if you're in a
fight they'll scream i'm gonna use my
own name gravano hit the hit the ground
you don't answer gravano hit the ground
they're going to shoot you with rubber
bullets yeah
you're never going to hear it the third
time if you're using a weapon or you're
doing something too vicious and you
don't hit the ground they'll use the
regular bullets they could do it either
way and you're not you don't know what
they're gonna do so i'm saying well
if it if i could fight a little bit and
hang in there a little while he's gonna
squeal out you know maybe they'll hit
him with some rubber bullets or
something i don't know i get it off and
i start walking in the yard towards him
and he's walking towards me
he's got a little bit of a smile on his
face
i'm a little nervous i'm going to say
the truth he's six three
yeah i mean he's and he's beefy and he's
nasty and he's killed a lot of guys i
killed a lot of guys so i'm walking
through his fair [ __ ] hands when i
get to him he grabs my head at almost by
my ears and pulls me out to him and
gives me a kiss on that
i love you oh he says i would have never
gotten the [ __ ] yard him a solid
that's solid and we liked it was he a
good chess player
very good really he's a and became a
great artist really yeah
he eventually got out of there and i was
in prison with him later on he's done
some of these tattoos on me oh he's done
those those are prison tats these are
all good
there's a role my old chest my back
every [ __ ] thing
and uh so anyway
he was good with me
and then i talked to him one other time
i have talked to them all the time but
i found out that they were going to hit
alfamilia is a mexican mafia gang
real dangerous
and they were going to hit the boss
black guy was going to hit him they were
going to take him in the yard they
wouldn't stab him or whatever
so i found that i told corfett
he said the the guy is right the cell
below you
which is even what they are when you go
down to the yard tomorrow bang on his
window
tell him about the hit and tell him
that i know about it too
why would he do that
he was first of all he's friendly with
the the uh
those two groups were were pretty tight
okay
they're different groups but they
respected each other enough that they
were tight okay
so i go down i bang on this guy's window
so i said bro i found out
tomorrow when you go in the yard
i make it like this you're going to get
hit
i know i know
fogarty knows and i you know and i'm
giving you this little message i know
sammy bro i already know about it but i
appreciate what you're telling me yeah
so now i i'm friendly with the abs
and now he tells all the uh familia guys
all the mexican guys
and i'm friendly with them
so when i go
past them and when i'm walking out see
me yeah you're good i'm good i'm over
both groups they're the most dangerous
two groups in the prison system there
i'm good
i'm [ __ ] good
but i didn't do it for that but it
worked out so i never really had many
problems in prison then it became real
to people
i tatted up
when i went in i was 55 i got a 20-year
sentence i tatted up and did certain
things
for a reason
i figured i'm going to get hit
in the joint yeah
whether if it's a fight
i'm now getting up in age i'll probably
lose but i'm gonna kill whoever did in
the fight especially if it came when you
won the fight now you kick him in the
face you better kill me
or i'll kill you
and people knew that in prison
they said this guy's for real he's not
racist he's not this he's not that
he's easy to get along with he don't
think his [ __ ] stinks like john gotti
yeah
so i got along with guys i didn't deal
with gay [ __ ]
drugs gambling money so those are the
places where you really get into
problems in prison you know oh really
okay oh yeah yeah you might need [ __ ]
yeah all of that [ __ ] or or the
television that's why sports i'm not
that good at it no more because they're
always arguing over the sports this guy
wants this that guy wants that they're
like it's nice [ __ ] [ __ ] they gotta
watch jerry springer yeah it's tough
yeah yeah yeah you know yeah right they
sort of the television is a problem
uh and uh drugs like i said is a problem
you just stayed away from all of it all
of it yeah but it's interesting because
even before you you did time like you've
always had respect whether it's in
prison whether it's in the the you know
the mafia it was just a respecting when
it came to you like everybody had
respect for you i always did and i still
do
till today i respect people i respect
people who are bigger than me smaller to
me
different things
like tell like
somehow john would always have you come
along because you could read people when
they were lying yeah john john john
would like always bring sammy because i
was good at reading things and people
one day he tells me he says sammy i got
a big meeting so guys coming down
business [ __ ] heavy stuff
sit by my side
tell me what you think after the meeting
i said all right so i was sitting there
and the guy is talking to him and he's
telling them all this stuff and john is
talking back and going back and forth a
little bit and uh
meeting's over he
says goodbye says goodbye to me he
leaves
he said what'd you think
i said there were certain times he was
lying to you
how do you know
i said when he came in he was all smiles
slid back in the chair it was real
comfortable
when you said this
asked about abc
this whole posture changed he stiffened
up
his hands grabbed the edge of the chair
his knuckles turned white yeah he was
squeezing the chair he was super
uncomfortable with your questions
that little jawbone moving he was teeth
was clenched intense he was nervous
and then he calmed down
and those things went away
then you asked them
xyz
again his whole body shifted
he was the tension i could see it in his
face in his eyes even a little bit of
sweat was coming above his lip
and his tongue was
coming in and out like a [ __ ] lizard
his mouth was dry
out of fear what an ass again what an
asset for john gotti bring you along
let me tell you this this part is funny
because this part is funny because now
two weeks three weeks he finds out
everything i told him was right yeah
just about not everything you know
so
that was good every time he's gonna sit
down with somebody sammy
[Laughter]
i don't know man sit with this now how
did i learn that i don't even know how
to [ __ ] eyeliner but i'm dealing with
bosses under buses guys who are lunatics
guys who are good guys guys who are
everything with life in debt situations
business situations
i've learned that for self-preservation
we're walking in the building and he
goes how do i know you're not [ __ ]
taking me to a room right now i go you
don't fair point i said i said
every time you went to a meeting when
you were in the mafia you don't know if
it's the last time you're walking into
that room
that's always a possibility yeah it's
always a possibility but not for me
because
it's a possib and and if you're worried
about it i'll tell you why you're
worried about it because you're [ __ ]
up
and you know you did something you
cheated your partner you did this you
did that it's guilt it's your own guilt
yeah that's what you feel like so you're
walking around i wonder if he knows i
wonder if he found that why is he want
to talk to me why does he want to talk
to me alone why does he want me in the
back room it's your own fear yeah yeah
it's you okay i do to this day i hate it
if i get it
i never [ __ ] anybody or lied or
[ __ ] i don't do that i mean i kill
people but i didn't do that
in other words
it was never a yes a business moves in
not business moves but closing offshore
moves but
if we're going to make a deal i always
live up to my deal with you yeah you
know some guys will say
i was dealing drugs
and we made ten thousand
nobody knows that i made this ten
thousand so
or maybe one or two guys know so i'm
going to go to the bush
and let's say it's a 50 50. but i'm not
going to give him 5 000. i'm gonna say
we made six thousand yes three yeah
so that little bit of cheating that you
did
you're always in the back of your mind
yep
i wonder if uh
somebody told he knew about it i wonder
if he told them i wonder if this ever
came out
it's wrong guilt so if you don't do that
then i don't walk around with guilt you
know you don't miss the life
maybe let's take another little break
from chatting with sammy the bull take a
little break if you want i don't care
sometimes there's no bull i'm in fort
wayne july 14th or 16th
cause because then i'm going to be in
milwaukee uh at the moment one day dude
no [ __ ] milwaukee
improved 20 21
get you some yeah all right but listen
i'll tell you we need to get you some
this saturday ufc 276 is here watch the
live cal bass fight commander thick boy
youtube and make money with draftkings
sports book the official betting part of
ufc they have such a great offer for you
guys this weekend they got a special
parlay for all the listeners and viewers
of firing the kid because listen they're
doing a three-man parlay your boy picked
them my picks are izzy suga and
barbarina all right good pick izzy i
think he gets it done against cannonaire
and i don't think he goes to the judges
then my boy sugars and step up to the
plate and beat pedro munoz and barbarina
listen barbarina gets down the first
round if he doesn't get a little dicey
for him he's a minus 105. he's still the
slight underdog there if you bet on the
three of them it's a parlay they boost
your odds all right just head to the app
right now under the ufc page to check
out my picks you'll see it under bread
and job bet on it and ride along with a
thick friend right now all customers can
place the same game parlay for
saturday's fight and if it hits you
double your winnings daddy download the
draftking sportsbook app right now use
promo code fighter new customers can bet
five dollars on any ufc 276 fighter to
win and get 100 in free bets no matter
what that's code fighter this saturday
at draftking sportsbook the official
sports betting partner of the ufc
minimum age eligibility streaks and
supplies see show notes for details
draftkings now let's get back to sammy
the bull you know you don't miss the
life
yeah cause before you answer that i was
gonna say like you know a lot of people
talk about the downfall of the gambino
crime family all that stuff to me and in
the movies too like whether it's
goodfellas casino i don't watch it to
the end i like the beginning blow i like
to begin and like when you guys it had
been so fun i think you guys didn't like
that rape then you're the social club
there and just doing your thing you guys
are in suits and then i listen to your
podcast and you're talking about one
time you and john gotti went to this
restaurant or bars and there's girls
there and john sends you over to pick up
the girls they're pretty girls you go
over to them but their dads are
somewhere in another crime family
they're like you can't do this john and
it's like i mean obviously you guys
weren't short on girls and people that
liked you because there's so much power
i bet it was so fun man besides like
killing us
there was definitely times that that
it's fun that's why the people loved the
mafia people
legitimate guys there's guys who are
tough guys who are not killing people
not in the mafia they're tough guys and
they love that because it's they almost
that's almost in them themselves yeah
could be a new a little bit him or a guy
ham it could be in anybody really i
don't know
no no well well i don't know
all right whatever yeah
yeah
my man i think it's in everybody
everybody and everybody yeah and that's
what makes the mafia so
lovable to people they kill themselves
so they don't care about that part but
their life
the the running around the broads the
cars the drinking the gambling the
joking sitting in the car
everybody's got that little bit of taste
of you know breaking the rule [ __ ] the
government you know you you after a
while you're bonded higher
[ __ ] by the government constantly
constantly so more or less you know the
hardest cases
for the government to win
are tax evasion cases
because the jurors every one of them
says i like this guy
i wish i could [ __ ] yeah yeah you know
what i mean so they could relate they
can relate to mafia guys they can relate
to some of the stories the fun stories
but there's a lot of bad stories and
there's a lot of good stories i feel
like just the bad stories get told
though and like the the fall down the
mafia it's like man to build that empire
that business like if you guys would
have done it legally i mean you're
talking one of the greatest business of
all time
legit he was legit making just off legit
business he was making 750 grand a year
no month no he was making 45 grand cash
a week
that was illegitimate but his legit
businesses were almost a million
and with this like my thing is is
you come to a point where you guys are
making so much money does nobody say hey
i think we're good yeah exactly like
what like why wouldn't pablo escobar
when he's worth whatever they said 12
billion dollars at 3 billion like i
think we're good for the juice go and
shut this down
is totally different see he's got he's
dealing with an illegitimate profit of
product drugs period he has to know when
to stop
we're dealing with a lifestyle now when
if we were dealing drugs you could tell
the guy
not to stop the life but
why didn't you you made enough money
with the drugs why didn't you stop do i
keep going oh right
but it's but it's the mafia is not made
for
the money end of it even though there is
a money in
you don't go into that you don't kill
for money there's a lot of things you
don't do for money money is in our guard
totally we want we all want to make
money we have an edge in making money
uh you could do legitimate things where
it does help you yeah
like you open up a bakery right
and uh you're a made guy
and i'm your captain
hey bro he just opened up a bakery and
he's doing this and the other thing now
listen tell your family your friends
everybody go to so you a legitimate guy
opens it up he's got to be
putting out good [ __ ] for the neighbors
and the people in that area to buy all
of a sudden you got 100 150 customers
coming in buying
who don't know how it is yeah even if
somebody says
i don't like that bread all that much
and i'm your captain
good and then feed it to your dog but go
buy it yeah yeah
yeah he's our brother yeah
yeah it's it's just so strange yeah i
mean it's it's a weird it's an extreme
lifestyle but i think too another point
is why uh when brian said you're coming
on i was happy because again i listened
to your pod i think too like you've
always been family first like you would
take you know do your mafia business
during the day but you'd come home and
you'd be with the kids like a good dad
i'd live two lives for sure i was a good
father a good husband he was talking to
his son he was talking to his son today
even though i cheated but i was a good
husband and a good father
and i'm right now i'm a good father and
a good grandfather yeah and uh
and uh but i was always a good mafioso
as well
that was my life and it wasn't just
feeling it it wasn't just stealing or
money it was my heritage yeah i'm sick
and i go back yeah it comes from sicily
so this is like my it's
it touches all my family not the the bad
part of it
but the heritage part of it yeah so to
me this organization means something
it's not just a gang anymore because i
was in gangs but that's [ __ ] yeah
you know it's me as the you know
[ __ ] but when this became it's part
of our heritage
you know so the irish when they look at
it
they have a heritage
you know the island and the english took
over and they fought for their freedom
and all these [ __ ] things so irish
guys look at it you know in this in a
way like that not every group
some groups do but
the mafia is just dedicated to that and
dedicated in other words when i look at
it in my neighborhood bensonhurst
brooklyn and i take the whole [ __ ]
benson north brooklyn
that's my neighborhood
that's my people
i don't give a [ __ ] who's in the people
you could be irish it could be a tiger
you could be chinese you could be black
you could be green
those are my people
i don't want you [ __ ] doing stupid
[ __ ] in my neighborhood and they
accepted you right
like they knew what you were doing oh
absolutely the whole neighborhood then
cause you you know he moved he wanted to
get out and move and he moved and tell
me if this is right uh sammy you moved
and the the neighbors down the street
didn't want their kids playing with your
kids because he was in the mafia yeah
where'd you move sam where did you move
well you were past that no
but they knew what he was yeah you know
so like oh these kids can't because his
kids want to play with these kids down
the street where was castellano was he
in palomanor
no he was in staten island he was on uh
toad hill okay where those are all the
wealthy houses oh yeah i i was on i was
in bull's head yeah it's not you know
it's a regular neighborhood blueprint
people down right and then you're dead
i was making so much money i moved to
toad hill
and i got a house what he's talking
about
and uh
you know i was out a lot so one day i
come back and i says how's everything
going we just moved there
she says they won't they won't play with
the kids the kids hated it damn so the
kids didn't like it i said well what do
you mean they wouldn't play with the
kids who
the house
down the block
um
barnes and nobles the guy who won barnes
and nobles lived down the block
so i said
he's they're not allowed to play without
kids
that's what they they don't want our
kids play with
i walked like i walked out of the house
i walked all the way down the block it's
pretty far
and i knocked on the door
and sent me the bull the wife in the
door
and you're mr barnes yeah
the wife the wife came out
and she says could i help yours i bought
the house over here i'm sammy saving the
boat you know i am oh yes yes yeah you
know who i am because you're not
allowing your children to play with my
children
because of me you want to know something
get the [ __ ] out of my way get your
husband
get your [ __ ] husband to come here
just read a book
so
and finally i mean it was
it's kind of scary yeah it was cool
oh my kids are playing with the kids no
then the guy came to the door
and he said
what happened
and i said she won't allow the kids to
play with my kids because i'm a gangster
bro
you know what i don't want my kids
playing with your kids but i want you to
move so your [ __ ] house can get out
of here you said that to you i said it
to him oh gotcha he said to me it would
have been dead
it would have been mr box number 20.
yeah so anyway i tell him that [ __ ]
whatever and then he's apologizing and
then i said sammy calm the [ __ ] down
it's not the guy the woman said it yeah
so i said listen pal i apologize for
what i said
tell your [ __ ] wife these are kids
bro
they got nothing to do with me you
let them people kids they're not
bringing their kids on a hit with never
doing something let them play let the
kids play exactly what i said let them
play and then i went back i was calm i
told my wife
get a real estate we're going to sell
this house and go back i want to go back
into
everyday slummy people
i want to be back over there i don't
want to be a different thing it makes
you feel good yeah yeah
it's not me i don't care if they never
talk to me but timmy did didn't you
threaten the neighbor too wouldn't you
like you'd be a shame
didn't you threaten him yeah yeah yeah
if you went missing anything just worked
out when did you do that and he realized
why did you do that because that guy's
not part of the business same way he's
like what am i
with
doing
here
noble guy yeah mr barnes got dealt with
oh you did you said that yeah yeah
that'd be a game of thrones books burned
down that's scary as [ __ ] yeah
so we were talking about how you can't
be a gangster anymore like with cameras
and the way [ __ ] is now it's just
different it's just different right yeah
you can't threaten people with violence
now right you know i mean you can but
payton yeah show them to 38.
[Laughter]
shitty baby
it'd be funny she took her wig off i'm
like it's not like that's just not hot
looking to see that movie where she
takes out two guns oh yeah yeah yeah
[ __ ] sammy he's always behind he's
always got one step ahead of you the
johnny key story to me
is one of the greatest stories
i've ever heard in my [ __ ] life the
way you by the way i told you by the way
everybody i you know i did this best of
and we're doing this podcast i've been
trying not to sound like i'm from
brooklyn but every time i'm around you i
i start talking like i was born and
raised in brooklyn but i'm not so just
in case there there is a little accent
there because i'm you know you kind of
catch that that energy now but the
johnny keys thing is the [ __ ]
craziest like your details here's what i
like
this is what's interesting you had to
get the guy in the van
so you say
i'm gonna stutter i'm gonna i'm gonna
i'm gonna miss my i'm gonna i'm gonna
stumble a little bit and that would not
be because the reason they're getting
yeah mr keys is because he was so john
john keys was was the hit man's hitman
he was there was a war going on right
you go and pose as a lackey as a jerk
off as a as a guy who's just like a
[ __ ] really you know and he has to go
tell him just tell him how you have to
go through the gauntlet of the guys
i just signed the contract with the
johnny keys i can't tell you that
you know you're going to be a little bit
because they might be doing a little
something called a movie about it yeah
just the other things can you ever get
sick of telling these stories
no like you when he goes when you're a
jimmy kimmel are you like oh [ __ ] well
it's the same story a lot of times i it
does get a little rough but
when you have to talk you don't have to
tell them when i started when i was
when i started telling it when i started
telling these stories
it was almost like a release valve i
live with the bottle yes i live with
these stories bottled up in me when i
started i was just talking to a
microphone doing a podcast i was there
was nobody there james carroll was
working with me
um he's a great director and uh
we were doing it it was like a release
valve
i tell so many stories especially this
johnny keith's story i become emotional
because
the only way i can remember or do these
stories is i i literally put myself in
in a focus that
i'm redoing it yeah so when i talk about
it i see his face yeah i hear his voice
i see his smile
it drives me [ __ ] nuts it really does
yeah but
now we're talking so many people who've
heard this johnny keys you don't have to
tell it
yeah let me interrupt you because what i
think is funny what do you confuse the
[ __ ] out of me sammy because the [ __ ]
guy i'm kissing my girl last night he i
hear him go like this yeah i don't we're
eating dinner i get my girl kiss and i
just hear him go oh
i'm like this [ __ ] guy is being moved
by my love affair with my girl he's
going he's kind of like oh that's so
sweet
and he tells stories where he's really
emotional now he's doing this series
he's got five episodes coming out and uh
it's called salvatore
and
the the director's like listen sammy
when you're gonna kill the guy you're
gonna be emotional you're gonna be
really emotional and he goes he goes he
goes i was there i don't know if you
know me bro but i don't get i'm i'll put
a hole in your face and [ __ ] ask to
pass the soul nobody's also sleep 10
hours like he had no problem sleeping
yeah sleeping take a nice long exit
sleep like a baby i said to you i go i
go but sammy does that make you a
sociopath he goes i don't think so
no you're just a [ __ ] computer i did
a thing i did a gig
in tennessee
there was a big
show we did and
and everything and then we went to
dinner with a whole bunch of fairly
wealthy guys and
they were paying to sit and talk and
have dinner so i was eating spaghetti
and had a spoon and the fork and
twirling the pasta
this one rich guy from england says
uh i'd like to ask you a question all
right and i'm twirl and he says
tell me how you felt right after the
murder
what kind of feelings did you have after
you kill somebody that might be a
murderer yeah
so i said well
and i stopped twirling i said
i'll tell you this way
i could turn around right now
put a bullet right in your [ __ ] head
and blow your [ __ ] head
wide open and you fall on the floor
i'm gonna call the waiter i'm gonna tell
the way to get this out of here
and uh clean it up and bring some
parmesan and go right back into twirl in
my eyes yeah my pasta
and put it in my mouth yeah the whole
table which yeah they all busted out
laughing even the english guys that's so
[ __ ] cool
that's so cool but i you know for me
it's like i asked him i go if you like
we have a religious obviously he's like
no
i'm not how could you be you know do you
ever think about what if what are you
going to say to god if you
you died all of a sudden it's like oh
[ __ ] you know i hate to get into god
conversation but what am i going to say
to him i'm going to say bro you know
come on you're wrong come on bro
you make lions and you make lambs
you make these things and you have
control and power over it
you made me yeah you couldn't stop me
yeah
and
whatever's gonna happen to me is gonna
happen to me i would tell them but
there's so many young little kids dying
of cancer and yeah danger being raped
and molested and
i mean
couldn't you have stopped some of that
[ __ ] yeah
you could have made a sign here
in front of everybody that maybe would
change a whole bunch of people's lives
not after that that while they were
alive mm-hmm yeah so thank god i i
believe in god because there's a lot of
things i mean
i don't know how we all started how life
started
uh
and
we all believe in god in all kinds of
different religions and i got to make
this straight now because there'll be
people hating on me who are in different
religions but
when i went to prison
in one part in 2004 i took away smoking
i didn't smoke for 13 years
and i went into one of these units i
wasn't in the hole no more and the
indians had a ceremony that had this big
blanket wrapped around
looking like a little bit of a tp and
they could smoke it's a religious thing
for them you're doing like native
americans native americans and yes and
so i i went to them i said could i join
this group because i wanted to smoke
hell yeah because you want to smoke
that's the real reason i'm being honest
face paint on just
no there's no smoking there's just a
religious thing for them yeah
so
uh
he said if the chaplain allows it in the
federal system you could change your
religion so i went to the
unit manager i went to the chaplain
and they made me a native american
indeed
so i went into it and i was smoking and
passing the pipe
and stealing some tobacco so i could
roll it bring it back to the cell when
the guard passes i light it up at night
and smoke but i got to respect their
religion we had to sit through they do
have a beautiful religion a road it's a
path to god they believe in god just
like everybody else right i had another
group of friends who were wickers
wiccans would you say
oh it's like a nature
pagan religion yes so he said sammy
you're not a native american indian why
don't you come and join with us and i
joined with them
and i learned this
what i learned in prison is that every
single religion muslim jews catholics
christians you name it
they have a path to god we all believe
in god why are we all fighting the
passage for money yeah oh for money all
the religions are [ __ ] i mean it's
for money
and you go in a pit that's their path
to god
and i don't care whose path goes where
and some of the places i believe it i
like
the the pagan religion
because they have
they believe in they're the only
religion that has
the woman
goddess of the moon the water and the
earth
god of the forest and the mountain
the woman is more important than the man
why
she obviously needs a man but she
creates life right yeah
she be creates life so she's more
important
they have a seizure yeah there is
there's a progressive thing about sammy
he'll order a vanilla latte with a
cinnamon sprinkle i'm like i'm dying
to bury somebody is that similar i'm not
putting the earliest [ __ ] in the world
like sammy who's like i'll get a swirl
get the caramel swirl with this
i'm
pumpkin latte the [ __ ] guy recognized
me he goes calan all right man wow i'm
like yeah this isn't my [ __ ] drink
right this isn't send me the box it's
the same with the bull's drink the bull
got the latte with almond milk
the black coffee
yeah yeah
so anyway
that's what i learned about the
conditions i listen i have i wear a lot
of different hats so
and uh
but uh lattes i like those as long as it
worked for you
when is it when can we see this tv show
you're doing this comes out july 6th
now um
and you're acting in it you're he the
guy's literally an actor it's like what
john gotti always wanted to do where
he's miking up last night yesterday i'm
we're on the pier and he goes and then
people arrive sammy they're going to
recognize them girls are taking pictures
with them and stuff and he just starts
laughing what's up he goes it's just
unbelievable john gotti this is all he
ever wanted this is all he ever wanted
and i wanted the exact opposite i was
always hiding in the shadows you didn't
want the talent and he goes now i'm a
[ __ ] like basically everybody wants a
piece of me he's got meetings right
after this he's got meetings with big
hollywood producers imagine you know i i
win any kind of an award so it's got me
thinking what the [ __ ] would you say or
do oh hollywood's gonna be clapping
iotis to john gotti
if he didn't [ __ ] me i would have never
been there
oh [ __ ] but is it did would you ever
think tell me like it's crazy whose idea
was it for you to start the podcast i
think it's so dope that guys like you or
even guys in different fields like tim
kennedy or jocko you know who are
special forces guys they have an outlet
now where they can tell these stories
it's a special skill set yeah and i
think one of the things that makes you
special obviously your history in the
mafia but your your memory is in impact
it's unbelievable it's better than mine
yeah you know i i have a guy who's he
did a video he said sami is lying
because he told a story about the stairs
creaking the guy who wore a red shirt
it's 40 years ago nobody could reap it
that he's lying yeah yeah i get it no
here's what i want him to do here's the
idea i want him to [ __ ] get up get
together with some other gangsters from
the old days
get together once a month or whatever it
is and tell stories or about play cards
dude a mafia fight companion that's
correct yeah that's correct how about
that yeah yes i think it's great we said
not even once we can do it once a week
we're sitting down we're playing cards
we're joking how many clowns are tuning
into that we're just we're just being
like we were in the past talking about
broads talking about drinking oh man you
know i love you guys talk about girls
listen you know a friend mike stymie was
running a phone company he goes to see
this captain's
girlfriend
she has this company so he's putting a
pitch on and he puts the picture on to
her and everything he comes back and he
talks to us
unbeknownst to us we're caught on tape
so he shows a picture
and i
say
he's got a gorgeous [ __ ] ass bro yeah
so we're joking like that what she looks
like and this that the other thing it's
the captain's wife it's it's it's his
girlfriend oh gotcha
and he's a serious dude so anyway i
don't know how
they let him know the feds about this
conversation
oh no well they're trying to cover and
now he's talking to me he says i don't
know who the [ __ ] did this this might go
who would do this
so i said bro
yeah it's
horrible
but i gotta tell you the truth bro
the ass part i think that was
he's like who said she has a wagon
that's a fast
the legs i think that was stymied
this girl comes up to him and she goes
like this she goes i've always wanted to
have sex with a sm with a little wise
guy because i like a little guy who's a
who's a gangster i've always wanted to
[ __ ] a a small gangster
he's sitting there he is and he goes
like this
i had a crush
i mean so
i said listen i don't think they get
much smaller than me but
so here we go and we're [ __ ] around
and a day later two days later
sammy you know who that what
you know what no oh
sally dogs is
niece another guy huh
his uncle
is a captain and yeah
they oh my god
so i went to sally dogs and i said sally
bro i got to talk to you
and uh
uh i was in the bar i told him story a
little bit and uh i wind up
don't tell me he says
uh i forgot a name now but yeah yeah
yeah i won't wanna
don't worry about the whole neighborhood
so
but i really didn't know who she was
yeah well sometimes you're supposed to
know those things i mean if you knew if
you didn't know they told me if you knew
you'd be in trouble yeah yeah if you
know would that be a capital offense
would you die for that or would you just
get beaten up not a girlfriend right
wife is off
well which one we're talking about no
i'm saying if it's somebody's niece or
something like that
well if you intentionally did that this
part you see this is another thing that
separates us from gangs we have to have
some moral and thinking and power
and
you know
it may just it may not be a killing
thing at that far down maybe but it it's
going to disgrace you you're going to
look like a piece of [ __ ] you're like
frowned up by the way do you know that
bro
it's it you know and it's like how many
of you can't trust him it's like he's
your close friend he's your partner and
everything like that so you go out one
night and you shoot this girl and you
find out it's just yeah these but you
say well he's my friend he's my partner
he's my brother yeah you're not gonna do
it no i'm not caught yeah yeah i mean if
he says go ahead do it yeah you know
you know yeah
you're gonna dip my toe
let me get my beak wet i'm gonna be fine
let me let me wet my beak a little tammy
told me i'm good i love that i mean what
might be my beak is right
he said i'm good you talked to him no he
said that to you yeah sami said [ __ ]
he's in arizona he gave me a goal
that's what we're gonna do from now on i
gotta call him he gave me a good thing
give me the green light man
i had to zoom with him before he would
come out
yeah i mean his assistant was like he's
got to meet you he's [ __ ] in the back
right there i'm like mr gravano thank
you so much mr guerrero i believe you'd
be a samurai if you'd been born in the
in in feudal japan
i'm doing whatever the [ __ ] i can't i
watched your whole you know i gave them
all
when he told me you're coming on but i i
mean i got my black belt and all your
all your stuff yeah all that man i read
all the books everything yeah i think
you you're the one guy who got [ __ ]
over you're one of the first guys that
the media portrayed it because john
gotti was so beloved but he also didn't
play by the rules and you've you're
quoted saying this is you guys were
playing chess you just beat him he
snitched on you you snitched on him and
he broke the code many of times before i
also think his recklessness is what
[ __ ] you get but here's what i said i
said
he was playing check-ins i was playing
chess yeah yeah and i checked baited him
yeah he did so
well you know when you came out with
this in other words when you did this
all my life i've been asked to cooperate
i got pinched all my life i never did
but you want to know the other part
is that after i cooperated with the
government so let's put that on the
table i cooperated against the
government in nine or ten cases to get
guys out of prison
the government don't like me either yeah
they're still called this [ __ ] sucker no
one's telling that story no no they're
not telling that but there's guys out
there who know it bulimia and it's out
there
in the underworld it's out there people
know those stories yeah and i have
people asking me for favors all the time
people who now
i shouldn't even say this but are active
and to asking me for favors you know
you know could you don't mention this or
back up
you know and i don't but are there other
guys that you would run into today from
the old life that you would have a
problem with that you could you would
fight or just or you guys would have to
cross the street
yeah if i i mean i don't i don't know i
i don't know about goddy junior but i i
don't know if what they would do but
there's a couple of guys that i would
like to
sit with
yeah in a room me and him and have a
[Laughter]
but i think to you when you go back to
gotti like think how many times you
saved his ass when you rigged the jury
break the jury think about going through
all that work three times the teflon
dawn it's like well no it's no it's this
guy that's one the teflon's here and
they you know what i don't talk about
junior or the sun and other people who
talk
they can't get out of that because it's
not something i'm making up the
government hated me for what i did oh
yeah so yeah of course they do you think
they like that i rigged all these trials
yeah and they know it factually now see
like they got the one of the cases
the guy got uh
you know he got three years yeah he gave
him three years he took 60k right
yeah we got that guy when i hear 60k i'm
like what yeah i guess you can go to
prison for life all you took was 60k no
i was getting the majority yeah she
always got him a job for 75 000 a year
and he was going to be our friend but
anyway that guy when he got found guilty
the feds immediately talked to him and
he cooperated and told the whole thing
word for word so they knew i wasn't
lying yeah so these things is that they
verified all of these things and they
said this [ __ ] sam he was relentless
yeah the things he was doing rigging
cases bribing people
threatening people i was doing
everything what sucks for the government
is your memory so impeccable and so good
is you can go through everything step by
step so i'll list another mafia podcast
whatever they go sammy says this i don't
know if i believe i'm like you morons
weren't there the problem is sammy's
[ __ ] memory is so good yeah you've
told the you can tell one person's lying
when the story's changing you know it's
hard to keep up with a lot well that's
what i told myself i said i believe
every word you've ever said i believe
every [ __ ] word he's ever said the
other guys i don't i don't i'm not
interested in talking to the other
gangsters i'm really not i don't like it
i don't like a lot of those guys they
just i don't like what they did i don't
like i don't know much about it yeah but
i listen to them and i'm always like oh
these guys this guy's just sound you can
tell when they're self-serving like
they're making themselves out to be a
hero or something you're like oh i don't
[ __ ] like this guy yeah i told you
your stories
are are structured in this [ __ ]
judeo-christian ethic it's like but you
were raised italian conservative family
benson nurse that's where my mother was
born and raised that whole side of her
family right in bensonhurst that that
culture is a very conservative there's a
right way there's a wrong way there's a
catholic way
you don't [ __ ] around yeah you didn't
step out of those those even with the
mafia like
with cause nostra they didn't kill the
family where these cartels go wrong is
they kill everybody they don't last it
destabilizes they were such a stable
predictable like my grandfather used to
always say to me he'd say i'll never
bother you brian as long as you don't
don't [ __ ] with them and don't don't get
involved with them but if you're on the
outside they're not going to bother you
now that can be interpreted differently
because if i have a business you guys
can shake me down
right no no no not necessarily not
necessarily i mean
we let a lot of things go we don't go
i'm going to give you a couple of
examples i was with paul castle and i
won the house it was a bunch of guys i
came in a little late and i was sitting
there he was part of this lana for any
of his listening was the boss of the
boss because he's a businessman and then
yeah yeah and he was smart so anyway
he's looking at television and there was
a strike with the garbage
and he's looking at television
and he says look at that
there's
the news people there's piles of piles
of garbage everywhere right
and they're on strike
so he says get in touch with jimmy brown
he was running the the association and
the union for this
and get him over here what the [ __ ] is
this
jimmy brown a little while they want to
go get him he comes into the house and
he says jimmy look at this bro
what the [ __ ] are we animals bro
tell them to pick that [ __ ] garbage
up from the
hospitals
from the schools
from the old age homes
we'll win the [ __ ] strike what is
everything in money
pick that [ __ ] up
so he he didn't know there was a value
says there's a value he cared about the
neighborhood he cared about children
hospital old people he kids he kid
and wanted to win and wanted well they
said the downfall of mafia might have
been the breakdown of family values
there was an article written about that
which is interesting like the breakdown
of the discipline when drugs got
involved and all that [ __ ] yeah like
henry's luciano you know these never
drugs right never never drugs you knew
carlo gambino no there was drugs with
that in the old age it was legal they
did drugs he might not he he was he was
lucky luciano was more of a pimp um yeah
he had brooks yeah how much what was it
what was the what industry did you guys
make the most money on construction
construction's a big monster car you
know thing you're building high rises
they're 50 back then they're 50 60 70
million dollars not at 200 and you would
get how much for a yard of uh cement
we were getting two dollars
per yard yeah yeah you give two dollars
guys to the mafia yeah but but i i heard
two tell me if this is wrong maybe i
speak out turn but i heard uh trump was
the one guy who couldn't get shaken down
when he's building [ __ ] in new york he
was surrounded by
other dudes
and he took he he knew like the the way
he was well he didn't really want to get
involved yeah but he wouldn't he paid he
paid the price in a way without
coming front in other words yeah he he
was up in his tower he had ex-fbi agents
it was his security
so you couldn't really push too much
with him smart but when the
when the prices came up or you wanted to
[ __ ] with him we had the union's
associates we could [ __ ] with him he
paid the the vig
more or less but not face to face
you don't want to come face to face he
was pretty smart about it and at one
point i was trying to get in his pockets
and uh
couldn't get there and i said [ __ ] him
too dangerous you know it was two days
yeah let's keep doing what we're doing
this is dangerous
he's got fbi wrapped around him so if we
keep pushing we're going to go to jail
yeah yeah that's impressive that's
impressive yeah trump is impressive in
that sense he was street he's street
street
because he knew he knew the game he knew
what was going on and he stayed pushed
back yeah that's the thing about him
with other politicians he came up in the
new york construction business you got
to be a rough [ __ ] dude you're
dealing with the roughest of the rough
you're dealing with criminals you're
dealing with everybody right right right
social unions
now you're dealing with the bush some
bush with jeb bush
aristocratic you're going to love
this whole thing with trump
a woman a news reporter calls me up
and uh hey sammy how are you this is
going back a little bit when they went
he they're hating on him he was the
president so she says uh
um
you were a powerhouse in the [ __ ] 80s
construction the unions and everything
yeah
she says that trump was a big builder
in new york at that time
yeah
come on tell me something
you know something about him come on
just between me and you nobody will know
yeah journalist yeah yeah
yeah so i said listen i really don't
know
too much about him he's a builder and i
never did anything really with him but
you know
i don't know i don't want to talk about
i want to get in the middle of whatever
she's begging me
begging me
please say i mean no one will know it's
just something between me and you i just
i just want to know
it's between me and you
yeah
you'll never tell anybody
no
okay
i wanted a job
a drywall job on one of his buildings
and uh
i had to do things to get it done
what
i got a friend of mine very beautiful
ghost
shohoka
so
i got her
and trump
and me
and we had a menagerie
together she's writing it down and i got
the job
she's on the other end
tell me her name
i said what the [ __ ] is the difference
her name you told me you're not gonna
tell me what's the difference you trump
and suffer so she says come on city tell
me your name and i started laughing a
little bit i couldn't take it oh yeah
she said you [ __ ] you're lying
you're lying
i tell you i don't know what he did but
one thing i could tell you i will never
have a menage a choir
[Laughter]
yeah but they're searching i know
it's just it's very it's very surreal
for me to uh
to have have you here just having grown
up in the 80s in new york city when you
were at the height of your powers and i
again i told you i used to eat i used to
always eat dinner at cafe sorrento and
the raven nightclub was two doors down
so i would see
you know when you're a young man you'd
i'd see some of some of your knuckle
breakers some of those guys built like
him come out one time i never forgot i'm
eating with my buddy and i see two guys
come out of the raven nightclub
big just barrel-chested dudes with suits
and collars no tie and they're doing
this and they were just walking and they
looked like they were going somewhere to
do something terrible but it was like
this energy this dark [ __ ] energy
when i was like god that's a whole
difference
but those knuckle breakers
they're they're in a disadvantage
because you know life was like
to get into an argument with a a chinese
guy or a japanese i don't know what the
[ __ ] he was an asian guy and
all of a sudden before we get ready to
really tumbly
i hear all kinds of [ __ ] noises like
in hand movements i said [ __ ] this
i'm gonna shoot this guy yeah i'm not
gonna fight him
i don't know what the hell is going on
so it's like that movie the same thing
with a real big guy if you're real big
and
yeah
he's fighting this guy
yeah did you work with the triads did
you guys ever deal with the triathlete
chinese tribes yeah
i dealt with
the chinese people a few times not the
triads the triads i believe
uh
oh i would would ate a vietnamese group
i think that try as triad goes for like
when you're in the so if you're a
chinese mafia you only know
you only know two other guys
so you only deal with two other guys
this guy only deals with two other guys
this guy only deals with two other guys
so they they
there's no chain of command necessarily
like it's all like he only knows two
guys this guy only knows two guys i
think that was the idea they tried to
create this weird you know i would never
want to be in that gang because it would
be so [ __ ] confusing
but they found the head of the triad he
was a guy you know the leader of the
chinese triad or whatever the mafia guy
they say was was sell he would do a food
cart he would he would make food he was
in chinatown sounds like a terrible
guest yeah they were called listen i
knew
johnny khan was was one of the bosses in
the chinese mafia johnny khan
and uh i was in prison with him when you
go over the bridge into chinatown you
ever see that big big tower
that was his building oh wow i did time
with him he hated john by the way in
prison hated him with a [ __ ] passion
and uh
so
and and i used to play cards with him
all the time
that's johnny khan and uh
the best thing story when he was telling
me says
sammy
american government no good
i said yeah tell me about it he said you
know my wife got arrested she's in the
woman's detention yeah yeah i know
some of the [ __ ] they just arrested
my girlfriend she in the same room
seeing the same thing
[Laughter]
i said your wife can your girlfriend in
the same prison together all these
things they're gonna kill him yeah yeah
but he was he was [ __ ] cool matter of
fact he knew a prince of somebody in
china
who gave him permission
he lived in the mountains
with a with a crew
wow
i mean an army or just about but he gave
him permission to cooperate about the
drug
situation
to so he can get out and then leave the
country and go up in the mountains over
there whatever damn so when i i was he
was telling me about it so he says
if you of course i don't plan to break
out when i was in prison the first time
because i knew we were going to lose
so he said if you get out
i know you got plans
if you get out
i give you my blessings you go there
you're living there
in the mountains they'll never touch you
i'll be there someday
eight points to john he says if john
comes
he come there
he'll never leave
he's just gonna hate him he would have
killed him yeah did you feel any type of
way uh sammy when uh john passed away
from uh throat i did absolutely
i
and we were attached at the hip
and if you don't have feelings a little
bit i i think something you're a
psychopath yeah but uh it did bother me
that he died like a [ __ ] animal in
prison i don't want to see anybody die
like that you know
i could hate a guy but
there's a limit like that i got
exploding about torture yeah people
i mean there's a limit to what you want
to do to somebody to get even even if
you want to kill somebody i don't
believe in torture and
should him in the [ __ ] head and get
it over when it's over with and i mean
you know you're going to torture the guy
like like roy demayo and people like
that did what are you sick or what yeah
you know you know
yeah really yeah
55 years old how old was he 16. no no no
uh
i know i think he was no he's four and a
half years older than me okay so he was
in his 60s i believe yeah
i don't remember exactly but he was in
his 60s um
61 not that old no he wasn't known what
was sammy the bull yeah
you were the one that everybody would
talk about though
especially
now there's his son and
there's all the gotti clan
so crazy yeah henry hill carlo gambino
was a was a [ __ ] gem
smile yeah oh smart
talented guy
and and and a legit businessman look at
that nose legit businessman oh crazy you
[Laughter]
but he was a great you know i went there
i was young i wasn't made and i went up
there it just says i don't even know why
they [ __ ] they took me there but he came
in he got up
what's his name sammy sammy said he
wanted a cup of black coffee he was so
like grandfatherly like took me over
gave me a couple of grow
i hear nice things about you but you
know banging my own but but just
it gave me such a good vibe i feel good
but i had a theory i said to sammy i
said some part of it because we had such
a good time yesterday i'm like you
forget
spaghetti who the [ __ ] he was
like i i said i feel like part of the
reason you stayed alive and survived
that life is because people liked you
because there was a camaraderie and
people considered you a friend or
something people looked out for you
you'd get tipped off on [ __ ] you know is
that is there any truth to that you
think or not oh yeah yeah i mean there's
a bunch of times nikki scarface was one
guy i won the war for him
the whole world knows that
nikki scarface
one night i came home
9 30 10 30 late at night i was and i had
a tough day i was exhausted
and i get a call
nikki would like to see you in atlantic
city that was two hours and 15 20
minutes away
and 2 hours and 15 20 minutes to come
back it's [ __ ] five hours and then he
wants to talk to me i said bro
is it important he wants to see you say
it's important i guess
am i right i tell them i'm on my way and
i went
i went out there and i walked they took
me into a a casino he's not allowed in
there
but i went to the elevator took me up in
the apartment the hotel and i went in
the room and uh
how you doing nick uh what's up
he says are you having trouble with this
[ __ ] bum
what bob
he's a boss now he won the war he's the
boss it's after the johnny keys head
uh
you're a boss john
i said bro
don't talk to me like that bro he's my
friend he's my boss
and i don't you want me to talk behind a
guy's back
you won't really want to put me in that
position i'm the under the boss i mean
you really want to do that
i'm saying i i know where you're coming
but
i i don't feel right
he
i've been coming through you from before
the war
all the all the time now he told me at a
meeting he wanted me to come true joe
butch away from you
why the [ __ ] would he want to do that
i i don't know
maybe i'm he knows i'm doing a lot of
things i'm tired maybe he's looking at i
don't know but
my understood this um don't you want to
take me away from handling the union
[ __ ] there's one thing taking me
away from my boss that we're like this
he's right but i'm not i didn't go there
i said i don't know
he said sammy
me and you have blood on our hands
together
we're in the war you won the war for me
bro
if you have a problem i got your back
and and think
why would he do this
think
you're a smart guy
um
that advice you know i
i think about it
but uh and he says i apologize that you
know i if i offended you you didn't
offend me but i don't want you know what
i mean he is my boss that could almost
start a war couldn't it that i mean
that's kind of sacrilege right yeah well
well he's saying he'll if i started well
he's going to go on my side yeah
you know he's going to have my back
basically what he's saying so i'm not
going to say nothing to put him in
position were you tempted
no to put him in a position absolutely
no he attempted to to say to nikki let's
take john out and i'll tell you no no no
no no you didn't really want to be a
boss no
no too much too much of a target on your
back well i i i wouldn't care if there
was an all time i know if he handed
himself well he could stay as the boss i
have no complaints being the underboss i
was making a ton of money everything was
good yeah
but uh
so anyway
he told me that and
i answered that way
but it left a little thing on the way
home i'm thinking
why would he want to take him
to go to joe butch rather than me
a boss going to a captain and directly
to him what are you bypassing me i'm the
underboss
and i made this guy the boss
me and him are like this which he
doesn't know 100
of our relationship
so i think maybe he underestimated that
a little bit
and it was a little bit of a bad call on
his part but that's how nikki took it
he didn't trust john but would you now
would you like because you and john were
so close would you go tell john this oh
no no
you wouldn't tell him no because
otherwise i would start a war it's not
it's not a war i may get the white guy
whack why would a guy
who's helping me right who's worried
about me why would i put him on why
would i say something stupid but in a
way though not telling john in that
situation is also can get you killed
why don't we give a [ __ ] about getting
killed i mean if he's right maybe i'm
going to get killed i wouldn't give him
up period i got you it was it was like
it's off the table
in my corner
when you got out of jail what's the one
thing after all that time that you
noticed about the world what was what
was scary what was different about the
world
the the first time yeah like when you
came out now you've been
20 years after john
the second time when you're in jail 20
years
now you come out into society
what was that what was that like for you
like what was the
was the one thing it was the worst thing
in the world because when i came out
most of this did i i went in in february
of 2000
there was none of these [ __ ] cell
phones the computers were not like they
are now
cars
total everything looked like a bubble
back to me it looked like the cars i
know i mean
not seeing cars for 18 years i mean i've
seen a picture or whatever but to see
them in reality i couldn't tell the
difference between a ford and a cadillac
and a mitsubishi or anything i saw it
all looked a little like unless i saw a
tag on it or something so
not seeing these things or not dealing
with these things for
just about 18 years
it's a whole [ __ ] trip
i remember i went with the i'm not sure
if it was my ex-wife or my
daughter we went shopping
and coming out with a car and a guy came
running
like
towards me
and
i turned around like
almost
wound up
cracking them
so my daughter was my wife whichever
what the [ __ ] are you doing guys running
to his car
and well i just came out of prison yeah
i'm still i'm i'm still in prison
no mom
i'm i'm in prison a guy comes running up
on you like that in prison you're gonna
guard against it you know what
prison is weird so it's i i still have
my prison
hatter
my mentality i got i need time
to come back into society and understand
what's going on and what's happening i
mean
it'll it'll happen but this guy just
came [ __ ] flying out of nowhere
i wasn't afraid of the mafia thing or
anything like that did you go to your
favorite restaurants did you go eat did
you want to eat something good for the
first time did you there's anything you
wanted to do that you hadn't done
definitely eat
yeah and i don't [ __ ] restaurants my son
cooks he's a great chef he's good yeah
tremendous and i wanted him to make me
some
pasta alla vodka sauce and stuff that he
could make he's a great cook some
meatballs and i wanted to eat more than
i wanted sex
yeah
i you know i missed certain things about
yeah eating
and i needed to get regular regulated
again
with
life
yeah with people
and you know
just and then i know i coming out with a
label he sent me the bull he's dangerous
and this and then i'm coming out after
18 years i didn't know
you know how to act or well you never
you never in a million years thought
you'd be doing
podcasts tv shows or dumbasses right no
no i never thought this came out 10
years ago food stamps
wanted to do a book
we worked on that a little bit i wrote a
little bit in prison for as a hobby i
it didn't go anywhere
and then somebody approached her about a
podcast
and she came to me and said would you
they want you to do a podcast they're
asking me to do it they don't want to
talk to you directly
but i need to have your rights if if
you're going to do it so i said i'll do
it god do it
and then my son put me on later put me
on facebook
without my knowledge i'm starting to get
14 000 calls i said what is going on
here bro why are these people calling me
i put you on facebook
oh
and then he put me on youtube
and then they start explaining to me
what's going on and what i could do and
stuff like that i'm glad they did man i
know such a fast yeah
it's great man we appreciate it yeah
yeah this is been a month this has been
great man you know we had a good time
that's what i did and and now i love it
because like now i'm not really in that
i mean i act but i'm you know i'm not i
don't consider myself an actor but i am
a people good last night
yeah and uh
i think i consider myself a producer and
i'm doing things
i couldn't find a better thing just like
right here right now honestly speaking i
couldn't find a better group of people
i'm so [ __ ] comfortable right now
yeah we got a good gig yeah yeah i mean
i'm
good people yeah and i'm very
comfortable with it i'm comfortable in
my skin
i talk i just say things i give an
example like i'm so natural with things
at the end of the show when i was first
doing this podcast and everything i says
or videos adios [ __ ] everybody
stopped my whole team you can't call the
whole country [ __ ]
i'm not calling them i said
well we'll just edit it out leave it in
it's my sign off man send me sign off
now we have t-shirts adios [ __ ]
cops adios
and every spanish guy i think alive
texts me hey [ __ ]
i love it
i think i made a [ __ ] a
legitimate word they put you in a hole
you found your way out yeah crush it man
yeah you know like like i said i mean
in charlie's angels we remember
three beautiful girls i got three
beautiful girls working for me i call
them sammy's angels
and i'm gonna do a little video in the
middle of the whole three of them but
whatever so just to show the boys back
in jail yeah life is tough you know i
took my time
down the on the dock over there she's
got these three three three blondes like
the mother a daughter and another woman
and he's got him like this he's like hey
and they're taking a picture he goes hey
fellas life is tough out here i got the
beast in my ladies three beautiful
blondes and his life is a [ __ ] out here
john gotti's just rolling over and it's
like we'll see
thank you man thank you so much my
pleasure i had a great time and uh
really brian i mean you i the the time i
spent with you i tell you like you know
i i was 15 hours with johnny keys in the
car i fell in love with him i fell in
love with you it took two days but you
and your family and your wife and your
partners and friends
really i
i've had a great time i appreciate it
really really yeah now we're gonna now i
gotta kill you
so it breaks your heart to have to take
right
it's gonna be a fighter in the sami
that's the whole plan well sam we love
you man
thank you i'm gonna say uh my
adios
[ __ ] yeah